uh okay let's let's let's take a step
into
let's take a step into more now right
um
murmurs right
uh murmurs of you returning back to
boxing you fight roy jones um
you [ __ ] start releasing these
training videos right
i want to go on record and say this
42 years old i don't think we've ever
seen
a boxer
of
uh your caliber talent greatness
re-emerge to the sport and
show that i am physically capable of
still doing okay
i'm 50 what was that 54 back then when
you fought roy yeah 54-55 i thought it
was one of them and my um
i don't want to say this
for that yeah it was the biggest um
pay-per-view i'm [ __ ] 55.
and um i would have still been doing the
situation but all of a sudden people got
greedy i'm saying this is fun it's not
serious this is just us having fun and
then i said hey ali is going to take in
the wife was it was it fun because i
mean there was a moment right
i know entertainment
i know mike isn't
isn't in the sport of boxing the way he
once was this is a great thing this is
like you said it's entertainment
but then mike there's a there's a moment
during the fight
where i go whoa
might look different right now
this don't
this don't look like mike is
is doing a show anymore did you did you
have a switch that clicked during the
fight with roy where it was like
yeah i punched a little sometimes a
little too hard but um
you got the people came to see a show
yes and roy was tough enough to do that
so they saw sure you can't be real you
can't go in there and play pity pat when
you're fighting no no but i i don't know
if roy wanted to [ __ ] take a real
punch and that's what he did and um
he took one that's what i'm saying but i
don't know if he wanted that that's what
i'm saying he had to be signed the
contract he had
uh i i i love that
there is a re-emerging
uh an excitement that's getting into the
sport right and i don't know if the
boxers understand what that was for you
and roy you and roy well not are you
paying homage to the thing that you love
you're you're you're lighting a fire
back in how do you feel about the mixing
of ufc the boxing boxing ufc
i think it's awesome
awesome and then from that happening
one day
we're going to have a heavyweight
chairman that's both m ms and what is it
ufcfc and the boxing champion he's gonna
be one guy
conquering both worlds i think it's dope
as [ __ ] going to happen you watch and
see who is mike tyson a fan of in
today's time what do you mean in boxing
who do you support who do you think are
there so many good fighters you know i
mean devin haney he's an awesome fighter
man tia phil lopez awesome fighter all
the listen
all the lightweights
and junior lightweight they're all monks
even the welterweights but they're all
the other
we have a great season of fighters
even the heavyweights are very exciting
you in the beginning of your career
right i mean jesus christ you're talking
about some of the [ __ ] craziest
knockouts you're talking about some of
the hardest punches thrown um
as you [ __ ] now look back at that
time whether it was you on the winning
side you're on the losing side
do you understand like
the [ __ ] destruction attached to the
sport i say who the [ __ ] is that guy wow
wow
who the [ __ ] is he
i have no kind of inclination no kind of
identification of him i don't know
nothing about that guy
wow
did you do you look have you looked at
older tapes of yourself yeah and i've
it's just
did you hear some of the [ __ ] i said
yeah
whoa
i'm like whoa hold on my daughter's like
dad
what do you never do like dad
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you said some [ __ ] no you said you said
i i will say that you've probably said
some of the scariest [ __ ]
uh you know in in the sport to others um
and that you know that goes without sad
we we know the world of mike tyson we
know the story mike tyson
you